hey guys Pete here this will be my
better call Saul season 5 episode 3
recap and review the ants are moving in
to devour the ice-cream cone that Jimmy
left behind at the end of episode 2 and
this is a solid episode with a lot of
great character moments spoiler warning
if you haven't watched episode 3 this
video will spoil everything that
happened in it go watch it first and
then come back for the discussion just
make sure you subscribe on your way out
as I'll be doing better call Saul videos
through the end of the series season 5
3rd episode is titled
the guy for this it was written by an
Turkish and directed by Michael Morris
in it we watch as the ants come together
around their ice-cream bounty but most
of our main characters spend the episode
apart from each other what I like about
this episode is the feeling of
inevitability and we'll talk about that
as we go of the characters Mike is the
most disconnected and we find him
drinking himself into a stupor he seems
to be doing a pretty good job of that
good enough that the bartender has
noticed and tries to cut him off Mike
secures another drink by surrendering
his keys and we realized that he's in
the same bar that he had a drink with
Verner in the last season when he
demands that the bartender take down a
postcard of the Sydney Opera House in
this process of demanding we see him
shift to actually asking and eventually
the bartender gives in and we can tell
that mike is struggling and that things
haven't turned around since we last saw
him with Cayley on the way home the
situation presents itself for him to get
a chance to act out some local tough
guys attempt to shake him down for some
money which doesn't turn out well for
them after he puts the first guy down he
almost looks disappointed that the
others don't take him on and that's it
as far as what we get with Mike in this
episode Jimmy finds himself on route to
meet Lalo and he's noticeably
uncomfortable at the prospect I
mentioned in my episode 2 video how
we've not seen Jimmy and nacho interact
together since season 1 and a lots
happened in that amount of time but
their first interaction was memorable
and I don't think Jimmy has forgotten
about the danger that Tuco posed and
he's not looking forward to whatever's
at the end of this rainbow either he
does meet Tuco's cousin Lalo who's happy
to remind
who his family is at first Jimmy thinks
that whatever is going on is related to
that but he quickly comes around to the
new situation and I like these two
characters together there's a lot of
similarities when you think about it
they're both smart they're both good at
manipulating things into getting what
they want here obviously Lalo has the
upper hand but I look forward to seeing
this relationship blossom we saw krazy-8
get caught in the last episode he wants
Jimmy to go inside Lalo has a
well-thought-out plan here it's all is
absolutely necessary to pull it off he
gives us the name of the episodes as he
tells him you're the guy for this
Jimmy's not in a position to say no and
Lalo really seems to enjoy that fact
Jimmy works out a price that seems high
enough to him but that turns out to be
less money than Lala has in his pocket
he pays him eight grand
Jimmy is now employed by the Salamanca
family and when you're in you're in we
see here by the pricing and everything
that Jimmy has a long way to go before
he's actually the Saul Goodman that we
saw during Breaking Bad but with this
plan he's well on his way later we see
things play out he goes to meet Domingo
he explains to him why it's there he
gives him something to memorize / what
Lalo told him to say then we get the
triumphant return of Hank Schrader and
Steve Gomez it's fun we knew this was
coming they didn't try to keep it as a
surprise I really liked the setup shots
where we see his stomach first coming
around then we see the badge then we see
his face I liked the back-and-forth that
they had that's what is fun about these
two characters there's a lot of their
dialogue that they have between each
other probably my favorite thing that
Hank did was he made fun of Saul's name
like he was like really come on that's
your name it's all good man really and
what stands out is that Jimmy really
rises to the occasion here they're about
to leave he reels him back in he makes
him think that they're changing their
plan in order to accommodate these guys
who don't believe them when really it's
all just been set up so we get a pre
Breaking Bad Hank and Gomi introduction
here
it's fanservice it's fun but it also
fits into the story things pretty much
go exactly how Lalo wanted them to
Jimmy came through big time he goes
later and he tells him about it he
explains that he's a confidential
informant now but that can actually be
positive that can work to their
advantage in the future Lalo seems
pleased after he takes off Saul tries to
get more information about what's going
on from nacho
but nacho won't tell him anything after
that we see not to go to Gus and tell
him what happened
Gus is upset that Lalo is essentially
beating him here but he can't really
stop this from happening now or else
that'll give up the game that nacho is
working for him as well as Lalo in the
end he's going to have to lose that
money at the dead-drops and that's just
part of the game and I think the real
takeaway here is that Gus is just more
motivated to destroy Lalo he'll be able
to make the money again he just wants to
take care of this situation the other
big nacho development happens at his
home we see him with his two living
companions the tweakers it's a pretty
funny scene where she's taking apart the
Rubik's Cube and she's taking apart the
remote control and he has like a box of
stuff that he gives her to occupy her
rather than her taking apart all this
stuff Papa shows up and it's just one of
the best set up scenes he seems
completely sincere as he's telling nacho
about this offer right before he pulls
the rug out from underneath him and says
that he knows that it was him we don't
know for sure but we can guess that that
probably makes sense Gus threatened
nacho with Papa last episode so we could
see that nacho might have set this in
motion
either way big surprise he won't take
the offer he will not run which just
further establishes what a messed up
situation
nacho finds himself in this is one of
those situations where that
inevitability comes in one way or
another the current situation that nacho
finds himself is and it's going to come
to an end it's not sustainable he can't
work both sides he can't protect his
family and he can't just walk away
especially now that his father won't go
along with it he can't do what his dad
once he can't go turn himself in to the
police that's not gonna solve the
problem and if he runs he always has to
worry that Gus might kill his family his
dad and
if he can't find him Jimmy returns home
and he finds Kim on their balcony she's
having a beer as a funny moment where he
takes her empty bottle and he puts it on
the railing in their conversation we
find out that Kim is excited because on
the next day she's only gonna be doing
work with her pro bono clients she's in
a good mood she asked Jimmy about his
day he's not gonna tell her about the
details of the things that have happened
but he does say that Saul Goodman had
his best day yet and it's notable that
she replies good for Saul's that have
good for you obviously so Kim has still
not embraced this idea that Jimmy and
Saul are the same person it makes sense
she fell in love with Jimmy not Saul and
and she's worried about what might
happen as he goes in this direction at
the courthouse the next day she gets a
call from rich from Schweikart and
Cokely
he points out to her that he respects
the work she does with her pro bono
clients and that he totally gets it but
Mesa Verde keeps the lights on and she
knows this while she's fairly fortunate
to be able to do this to balance out the
work that she doesn't like she does work
for Mesa Verde and she does have a
commitment to Swaggart and Cokely so she
has to take off she has to drive what
looks like about a two-hour drive on the
map from Albuquerque where she has to
deal with this guy mr. Acker this whole
Kim part of the episode is what takes it
from being a really solid episode into
being what I think at least in my
opinion is one of the best better call
Saul episodes certainly my favorite of
the season and I really enjoyed this
whole thing and it's interesting to me
that they chose to use very Corbin who I
know from northern exposure you may know
him from many of the other things that
he's done but them choosing him as
someone is a notable actor makes me
wonder if this mr. Acker might have a
longer character arc than just this one
episode either way a whole lot happens
between these two much in the way that
nachos dad is not going anywhere mr.
Acker also has no plans on vacating his
home legally he does have to go I mean
we can feel for him we understand that
he built a house where he had a hundred
year lease but there was always a clause
that they could sell it and that's where
he finds himself Kim tries to reason
with him
when that doesn't work she gets a little
more aggressive to the point of calling
him out eventually saying you know why
are you special everybody else did what
they were supposed to do and you think
that you have a reason that you can not
play by the rules and we see her
frustration Paige is actually happy that
she brought it to an end this doesn't
sit well with Kim though and she comes
back later in the evening and when she
goes into the property like I was on the
edge of my seat like something bad was
gonna happen it felt really ominous I
wasn't sure if he was gonna be dead like
he committed suicide or there was gonna
be some other thing waiting for her on
the other side of that fence the
important thing was that he called her
out for being a rich person that does
good things to make themselves feel
better which Kim is not really a rich
person she's on her way to being that I
guess but we know her as a good person
or at least someone who tries to do good
and he only sees her in this light true
to her nature she brings him real estate
listings and tries to explain her own
background which is great for us because
we learned some things about Kim that we
don't know I mean we know that she's
self-made we know that she comes from
humble beginnings but I imagine this is
a true story that she's telling and he
doesn't really accept it
he thinks that she's just saying what
she needs to say to get her way and it's
fascinating it's really powerful and I
can't wait to see where things go from
here when she returns home this time
it's Jimmy that's waiting for her on the
balcony he already has the beer he
offers her one there's no dialogue
between the two at all she lights
cigarette they share it he plays a
little game where he's acting like he's
going to drop the bottle and then she
just goes ahead and whips one full off
of the balcony and they throw a couple
more and it's this great moment where
they connect on that level of like doing
something bad to feel better about how
bad everything is it's really just a
classic scene and what I'm sure is to
become a classic episode one of those
things that makes this show really great
is that we don't know what's gonna
happen to Kim we're rooting for the
whole way and I really loved how they
brought this all together at the end mr.
Acker was a great character to pull some
of these feelings out for her and it's
fantastic
see Jimmy there and how they have that
unspoken connection and are able to
comfort each other all in light of the
fact that we know things are going to
end badly for them and that's pretty
much everything that happened there's a
lot of small details here obviously it's
fun to see the Breaking Bad characters
return
I like seeing how Jimmy turning into
Saul isn't a light switch it's a gradual
transformation we see why he's a good
Saul Goodman in this episode but he
still has reservations about it so I'm
gonna wrap it up there there's so much
more to talk about hopefully this week
I'll do some extra videos because I
think this season really is on track to
be one of the best let me know in the
comments what you guys thought what was
your favorite parts what are you most
excited to see where do you think things
are gonna go from here please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you're not already
subscribed let me know if there's any
bonus videos you want to see any other
details or Easter eggs you want to talk
about thanks for watching guys I will
talk to you soon